ceremonias fúnebres que parecen no tener
fin enlaces Jordania ocupada
[Aplausos]
[Música]
aquí en la ciudad de yin familiares y
amigos despiden
muerto durante la más reciente incursión
de las fuerzas israelíes en un
campamento de refugiados palestinos abd
para el gobierno israelí un terrorista
miembro de la organización islamista
jamás y responsable de matar a dos
judíos en un asentamiento en jovara el
26 de febrero
los combatientes de las fuerzas armadas
israelíes eliminaron al abominable
terrorista que asesinó a sangre fría a
dos de nuestros mejores hermanos de
halel y jagel Janet boogie
como lo repito sin cesar aquellos que
hacen el malpón en su vida en riesgo
para los palestinos abdel fatah un
mártir
el estado de huelga y el luto por los
mártires de yin es lo mínimo que podemos
hacer
los incidentes que ocurren en nablus o
en hebrón son incidentes enormes y la
gente está agotada
desmiente la responsabilidad de pataje
en el crimen de los dos judíos
hace 11 días Abel estaba en su casa y
luego salió a las oraciones del mediodía
y a buscar trabajo
estas imágenes grabadas mediante bodycan
por los soldados israelíes muestran el
momento exacto de la redada del martes
que dejó cinco palestinos muertos además
de abdel según el Ministerio de sanidad
palestino
una ola de violencia desatada en las
discordania ocupada ataques terroristas
contra colonos judíos reales mortíferas
en campamentos de refugiados palestinos
por parte del ejército israelí con más
de 160 palestinos muertos el año pasado
los últimos meses han sido los más
violentos en cisjordania desde 2006